the White House says if President Trump
imposes tariffs on imported steel and
aluminum
they might not apply to some American
allies the president is expected to
announce the new policy as soon as today
even though a growing number of
Republicans are urging him to reconsider
Jericka Duncan is at the White House to
Rico good morning good morning the
president is meeting with his cabinet
this morning it may very well be his
advisors the last opportunity to express
their opposition or even dissuade the
president's plan of imposing tariffs on
imports of steel and aluminum we're
moving fully ahead White House press
secretary Sarah Sanders said the
president would slap tariffs on steel
and aluminum imports despite mounting
opposition he feels like the United
States has been taken advantage of for
far too long
Sanders acknowledged that US allies
Mexico and Canada could be spared but
exemptions would be decided on a
country-by-country basis EU officials
said Wednesday they might retaliate with
penalties on US products ranging from
cranberries to peanut butter to orange
juice President Trump addressed that
threat earlier this week
if they do that then we put a big tax of
25% on their cars and believe me they
won't be doing it very long fearing a
trade war could erupt 107 Republicans
sent mr. Trump a letter Wednesday
expressing deep concern about the
prospect of broad global tariffs warning
the move will make US businesses less
competitive and US consumers poorer
National Economic Council director Gary
Cohn who announced he'd be leaving the
White House had reportedly failed to
persuade mr. Trump to drop the tariffs
the White House is getting hollowed out
cones absence worried Democrats and
Republicans on Capitol Hill well I'm
concerned who the president will turn to
for advice Republican Senator John
Cornyn who sits on the Senate Finance
Committee said that Congress really
plays an important role in all of this
he actually said that he spoke with the
Senate Finance Committee Chairman
Republican Orrin Hatch they plan to now
hold hearings on trade issues and
Harris Nora alright Jericka Duncan at
the White House Thank You jurika